bush en tout cas la musique pape et vous
le savez nous la devons en grande partie
à cet ensemble de jeunes anglais les
buts s hélas à communiquer du célèbre
groupe vient d'annoncer que c'était bien
fini de leur association et que jamais
plus une remonterait ensemble sur une
scène il y a dix ans pourtant dix ans
déjà
tout avait commencé dans une toute
petite cave de liverpool les beatles ne
joueront plus ensemble pour quelques
motifs que ce soit financier ou autre
cette phrase prononcée par paul
mccartney le chef de file des beatles
n'est pas pour étonner le monde du
spectacle
depuis quelques temps déjà george
harrison et ringo starr john lennon et
paul mccartney
les mousquetaires de la pop music ne se
voyait plus très souvent déjà en avril
dernier on parlait de séparation et
pourtant il y a une dizaine d'années ce
fut l'explosion la bombe anglaise
les chansons des beatles était sur
toutes les lèvres leur effigie ornaient
les chemises les oreilles
l'autorité musicale du groupe étaient si
fortes que la reine d'angleterre
les fiches chevalier de l'ordre du bain
et comble de grandeur
les beatles furent côté m
alors pourquoi le groupe se sépare t-il
la raison dans les pas encore connue
quant aux fins bien sûr ils seront déçus
mais ils auront la possibilité d'écouter
sur leur électrophone et bien les
beatles à la retraite déjà il ya je vous
le rappelle dix ans c'était le temps des
années 1960